let's hear from President Putin who was
speaking about the war in Ukraine a
little earlier appeal to all citizens of
different Generations
ages nationalities ethnic Origins
to unite us with this great historic
Russia soldiers officers volunteers who
are now fighting
which clearly threats threatens other
countries
from their integrity the aim of the West
is to weaken bring down and destroy our
country they clearly
speak about the fact that in 1991 they
were able to bring about the collapse of
the Soviet Union now they want to bring
about the collapse of Russia
deadly enemy
they have had these plans for a long
time
Russian plans
threatening war with our country
in 2014
using the Armed Forces
organized a genocide a blockade
and refused to recognize the power the
government
any peaceful settlement in dumbass
then there's a threat of nuclear weapons
which is absolutely not okay
and that would be inevitable
which would then have led to an attack
on Russian Crimea so this decision was
absolutely essential
and the main aim is to bring all the
territories of dunbas
Republic has already been
cleaned of Ukrainian of Ukraine for
eight years the Kiev regime
has been dragging this out for so many
years
our parts are military units
acting in
educated correct way step by step they
are freeing the country
freeing Villages and towns
and the government and Ministry of
Defense
against regions
the Russian army supporting including in
a medical and social way I'd like to
draw a particular attention to the
provision information
in the technology
the main task is to free
with the ministry of defense and General
headquarters to free them from Nazis
as well as the zaparosa region
as a result
fighting line which is just thousands of
kilometers I want to say publicly that
following the beginning of the special
operation and negotiations the
government reacted to our proposals with
opposition and these proposals above all
concerned providing security to Russia
but it's quite clear that the West was
not interested in a peaceful solution
and they're making compromises they just
wanted to break down all negotiations
foreign
against its own citizens following the
armed coup of 2014. the politicians are
afraid intimidated intimidated
threatened
in Barbarian ways we know the majority
of people of these new Nazis on the
territory
do not want to be under the Yoke of this
Nazi regime
that the neo-naziers had captured their
areas
were killing people
killed
regions in Zappa Russia
about half a million people many of whom
had to become refugees
upstairs there's constant artillery
there is constant firing
they are attacking hospitals and schools
to carrying out terrorist attacks We
cannot put up with we cannot have any
moral rights not to support these people
cannot not respond
and stop them from defining determining
their lives and therefore the Republic
and the military Administration
I've decided to carry out referendums
have appealed to us to rush with a
request to support the regime
we are doing everything to ensure the
security and Independence
self-determination
and that decision about their future
[Music]
is one that we support
adequate
and with which we are facing
for the protection of our people and
it's sovereignty and integrity provide
the security of the people and the freed
territory liberated territories to
support the proposal of the ministry the
headquarters of the Russians Federation
of a full mobilization
I want to say tourists services
foreign
service in the armed forces
military service
have additional training
the decree on this but partial
mobilization partial mobilization are
repeat
they will be informed today by the
federal assembly
today on the 21st of September be
informed including the main regions
provide or Central
means for the military commissariate
for mobilization status
increase the production
of military equipment in turn or
material questions resources Financial
questions
must be solved by the government quickly
dear friends
the aggressive anti-russian policies
we constantly hear threats against our
people
irresponsible politicians in the west is
speak about
defensive weapons the threat of
offensive weapons
such terrorists strikes including the
use of Western weapons is something
including going up to our borders to the
coast region
planes ships
satellites
NATO is threatening the whole of Russia
Washington London Brussels constantly
putting pressure
on our territory
foreign
Russia could apparently use weapons of
mass destruction or nuclear weapons
those who allow them to sell us to say
such things I want to remind them
also has different means of Destruction
components and more contemporary than
NATO and with the threat to the
territorial Integrity about the country
it's a defense Russia but certainly use
everything all means that we have
available
citizens of Russia can be convinced that
territorial integrity and our
independence and freedom will be
provided and short I emphasize this one
more time with all means that we have at
our disposal
and anyone who tries to Blackmail us
with new kids in a nuclear way
know that this can come back to them are
historical tradition of our people
is to have a peaceful leadership
motherland we will do this and we will
I am convinced in your support
confidence for your support
okay if you were just uh joining us
we're just hearing that from President
Putin of Russia giving a pre-recorded
televised address uh there to the public
announcing a partial military
mobilization of the Russian army we were
expecting an address from him yesterday
a live address where there was
speculation he was going to order a full
mobilization of forces as well as unveil
his plans to Annex parts of Ukraine
which are currently held by his troops
but instead that speech never came but
now indeed we have heard from President
Putin there in a recorded message let's
go to our correspondent Gabriel zondo
who is live in Kiev and see what he
makes of the speech so announcing a
number of times that this is a partial
military mobilization of his army what
exactly does that mean do we think
well this is certainly a very defiant
speech by Vladimir Putin and there are
three things that really came out of
this that struck me number one as you
mentioned uh he did confirm a partial
mobilization of Russian military forces
he stressed that it was partial not a
full mobilization what exactly will this
look like he didn't say we'll have to
find out in the coming hours as more
details come out from the Kremlin on
what this means in general a full
mobilization would mean in general that
any uh military-aged man 18 to 60 years
old roughly could not leave Russia and
would need to join the military uh it's
unclear if this partial mobilization
means that or not so we'll have to get
more facts on exactly what this means
but seriously clearly it is an
indication that Vladimir
Putin wants to ramp up the amount of
military forces that he can call on to
fight this war in Ukraine so no matter
how you look at it it is definitely
an escalation if you will and a
realization that perhaps the Moscow
needs more troops in Ukraine to achieve
military goals now beyond that he did
also confirm a very big headline out of
this speech is that he did confirm that
he is moving forward with referendum uh
votes to take place on Ukrainian
territory that is occupied by Russia
right now he's he mentioned Don bass a
lot the regions of luhans and donyesque
he said that they will have accepted a
russian-imposed officials in those two
regions their request to hold referendum
uh votes he said that they will move
forward with that and he also mentioned
the region of zephyrha as well interest
instantly enough he did not as so as far
as I could hear mention her song the
region in the far south what's
interesting about this is what Vladimir
Putin is saying is they're going to move
forward with referendum that's the first
step to full annexation in those three
regions two of the three zaparesia and
donyesque Russia only controls about 50
percent of those territories so this
will be very unprecedented and very
interesting to see how they plan to hold
this referendum uh in territory that
they don't even control all of in fact
in zapparesia they don't even control
the regional capital of that area either
beyond that uh the other thing that
struck me was towards the end of his
speech clearly mentioning uh nuclear uh
saying that Russia will use all of its
available means to defend what he calls
Russian sovereignty and Russian
territory and even mentioned you know
the the insinuating that all options are
definitely on the table definitely
that's something he's mentioned in the
past or hinted at the past but you heard
it straight from Vladimir Putin's mouth
right there that that he is prepared to
use any means necessary to defend uh
what he considers to be Russian
Sovereign territory and Gabriel let me
pick you up on the the plans on the
referendum that we are now getting more
details about a lot of criticism from
the West on that yesterday
and how exactly does he plan on doing
this when the country is in the middle
of the war
well the referendum we've heard from
local officials Vladimir Putin did not
confirm these details in his speech just
now but from local officials here again
these are Russian imposed officials in
these territories they're claiming that
this is going to be a referendum that
goes on for five days and it will start
this Friday on September 23rd how
exactly they plan to pull this off is
really anybody's guess it seems to be a
sort of hastily put being put together
uh
uh it appears that one official in
Japanese said that this will be a a vote
that will take place uh on the internet
and by mail but the internet is not
doesn't work in some of the regions that
they're talking about uh and also by
mail mail service doesn't work in some
of these regions either uh again they're
they're saying at least from local
officials that only
people that live in russian-controlled
territory Russian military controlled
territory will be able to vote highly
complicated how they're actually going
to pull this off again all three regions
in Vladimir Putin just said that he
supports these this referendum happening
in all three regions have fighting
happening in them and front line
fighting shelling back and forth and in
fact in donesque it's actually the
ukrainians that have been pushing the
offensive into the donesque region
retaking some territory there and it's
the same in zapparesia as well so how
exactly this they plan to pull this off
is really anybody's guess but I can tell
you the view from the International
Community and the view from here in Kiev
is uh that this is simply a joke they
sort of roll their eyes at this and say
and say this is in their words a sham in
fact uh president Voldemort zielinski
said at an address last night he just
almost brushed it off as saying that
this is just a show and it won't change
anything we also heard from Washington
officials there including uh the the
Secretary of State uh in from the United
States calling this simply a sham and
that it will not be recognized any
referendum on Ukrainian territory by
Russia will simply not be recognized we
heard that from uh France as well uh so
the Western Community is sort of
rallying around that they're just simply
not going to recognize this and almost
shrugging their shoulders but with that
said this certainly will complicate the
situation in Ukraine both for the
ukrainians and the West in General on
how Ukraine will respond to this because
certainly this will take the war
potentially in a new trajectory
okay good to speak you the Gabriel
Elizondo there for us in Kiev